[Applause]
it is interesting but you keep on seeing
this criticism pop up about the fighters
not getting paid enough yes
and then then maybe we should bring up
the tweet but jake paul
who is continued to do something so
[ __ ] amazing the gravity this kid has
been creating around him
is is is unbelievable the entire arena
is chanting [ __ ] jake paul yeah
at an mma card ufc 261
which is one of the most interesting mma
cards in history
it's not like it was boring right and
they're distracted and looking for any
bit of distractions
like all right let's just say [ __ ] jake
paul every fight is [ __ ]
scintillating and he still gets the
arena
and the first of the fighters together
first time what's that first time you
have a stadium full of people and
they're changing
the first [ __ ] time and i know that's
driving dana white crazy absolutely
[ __ ] crazy and the fighters daniel
cormier going and talking [ __ ] to him
francis uh uh camaro when we
got brought up was like yeah man that
kid like you can see he feels away
everybody
feels a way about this kid yep and
that's a [ __ ] that's a
that's part of his genius really yeah
that's his marketing you saw him
standing up like taking pictures when
everyone's chanting and he's just
looking at him
yep yeah the kid knows what he's doing
man and
so he he uh posts this on twitter he
goes and he goes at uh
dana white dana you claim that you would
bet 1 million on me losing
set up ask her to train with freddie
roach gave him full access to ufc
pi and he still got his ass handed to
him seems like you are the
uh seems like you're the real douche not
ariel in my third fight
i made more in total pay than any
fighter in ufc history
maybe it's time to pay your fighters
their fair share
no wonder they all want to get into
boxing dana you say you make the fights
the fans want to see
so hurry up and make jones versus nganu
pay them their fair share
10 million purse for each guy plus
pay-per-view
why are ufc fighters so underpaid versus
boxers
why did i make more in my third fight
than all but two
khabib and conor ufc fighters have in
history i know why
dot dot no spelling mistakes
that didn't impress me he hit the right
there like
like syntax he's only had three fights
give him 10 15 fights there'll be some
spelling mistakes for sure
but it is well it's a [ __ ] great
point dude so he's
what's really interesting about this is
he's driving the wedge between
the fighters and dana yeah and i thought
dana did a very good job of like
keeping the fighters on his side the
fighters seem very grateful for dana
and probably because he kept them
working i.e fighting
during the pandemic right and if you're
a fighter who makes their living
fighting and you can't even be around
other people it must be terrifying how
am i going to feed my family like oh
[ __ ] this guy's working hard to make
sure we can keep fighting keep getting
paid
thank you so much salvation but he's
driving the wedge between
fighters and dana and now between fans
and dana
the fans want jones and ganu he's saying
dana is stopping that from happening and
dana's
alleged greediness now who knows if dana
is being greedy with that money i'm
really curious to hear what
dana's spending on building the ufc
itself yeah
because it is undeniable that these
fighters get to take advantage of the
brand that the ufc
is yeah you immediately fight on the ufc
and all of a sudden you are legitimized
they're gonna build you up and if you
have exciting fights they're gonna make
you a [ __ ] superstar on their
platform
that costs money i don't know how many
millions it costs
i don't know how much less they have to
pay fighters versus
boxing where you don't do that for your
fighter but i'm curious if i was a young
fighter
if that'd be worth it if i'd be willing
to take that percentage
of my pay and give it back to the
promotional company and have them do it
or if a young fighter would go hey just
pay me the full amount
i'll take care of my own promo right but
maybe the ufc goes
we're better at it than you yeah you
will make more money if you go along
this and the guys that are at the top
they might not make in those [ __ ]
fifty hundred million dollars
they're not starving yeah you know what
i'm saying like is he's still making
millions
is he making the company tens of
millions
yes should he get more because he's
making them
some would say yes i would say yes just
because he can promote [ __ ] outside of
what the ufc can do
but there are boring fighters that need
that ufc
yeah promo and it's worth whatever
they're taking out of their salary
because they wouldn't get those fights
because they're too boring outside of
the fight itself
yeah it's tricky not to mention without
ufc
existing what was the alternative before
that
you know i mean like obviously or things
like that but like
if you're a young you know mixed martial
artist in like 2005
like yeah like the k1 tournaments were
really big out there in japan and where
they make pride
i think k1 was purchased by pride or
vice versa
but yeah i don't know if they were
making tons of money to be honest and i
doubt it you could argue the rising tide
of ufc just lifts all ships that would
be his problems that's what i would be
curious about like these fighters are
making
maybe not as much as they're supposed to
be paid by the promotion whatever but
they're making more than they would have
gotten paid had this thing not existed
yeah like i don't know what the average
fighter salary was
prior to like yeah the counter could be
sure you don't get paid like boxers
boxing is also dying
so that's the other thing that people
don't realize about boxers right it's
like you see the top of the top making
all this money
yeah and the bottom of the bottom make
nothing like i don't think the bottom of
the bottom boxers are making
more than ufc fighters right like i
would argue that there are more ufc
fighters
that are making a functional living in
other words they can eat just off their
ufc money
than there are boxers just the top of
the top in boxing
is what makes all the money right so
that money in the ufc is spread over far
more fighters
which if you're a ufc fighter for a
living chances are you're not going to
be the top of the top
so it's nice that you can make a [ __ ]
living doing the thing that you love
even though it's very dangerous
whereas a boxer you're basically working
as well as boxing yeah
until you get a sponsor which is a rich
guy that wants a piece of your purse in
perpetuity
right or you get a huge [ __ ] fight
but
most boxers have [ __ ] day jobs yeah i
guess a lot of ufc guys do as well
right i'm just saying it's easy it's
quicker to get to that middle
tier who knows if it's right
you